Buenos días Lo que se espera hoy es que
primero terminen las plenarias a mis
espaldas se están reuniendo para las
últimas declaraciones Y a partir de las
tres de la tarde hora local ya será la
plenaria de cierre Qué pasa allí primero
se van a reunir las conclusiones de los
cinco diálogos interactivos que han
ocurrido de manera paralela a esta
sesión mayor estos diálogos tienen que
ver por ejemplo con el agua y el
desarrollo la salud el clima y la
resiliencia porque como usted bien lo
dijo esto tiene que ver mucho con la
contaminación y con el aumento de la
temperatura y luego de eso todos los
gobiernos se reúnen para las
conclusiones de la plenaria se espera
que de allí salga la acción de la agenda
del agua que es donde los países van a
plantear los compromisos con los que se
comprometen con los que prometen
proteger más el agua hasta ahora hay
cerca de 600 compromisos voluntarios y
de ellos alrededor de 120 son propuestos
por gobiernos el resto son de empresas u
organizaciones civiles hasta ahora lo
más mencionado ha sido que se cree un
enviado especial de la ONU para la para
el agua y que esta conferencia se
realice más a menudo pues la última vez
que ocurrió fue hace casi 50 años en
Argentina